amber heard's legal troubles are far
from over
because just weeks after losing against
her ex-husband johnny depp in a
defamation trial do you find that mr
depp has proven all the elements of
defamation
answer yes
e.t has learned that she's still being
investigated in an ongoing perjury case
in australia so what's amber dealing
with now well a spokesperson at the
australian department of agriculture
water and the environment tells et
they're investigating allegations of
perjury by the actress during court
proceedings for the 2015 illegal
importation of her two dogs into the
country perjury is of course lying under
oath you'll recall when amber and johnny
were still married they brought their
two yorkshire terriers pistol and boo
into australia without declaring them
despite the country having a strict
quarantine policy
you and your wife got into some i don't
know is it legal trouble is it is that a
fair way to describe it
i mean if if that's legal uh trouble
uh it's it's by far the most interesting
i've ever
experienced
yeah it's something johnny went into
detail about with jimmy kimmel he went
to australia didn't shooting pirates of
the caribbean indeed
and the um
your dogs you brought dogs into the
country you did you smuggle the dogs
into the country no the dogs were
we we
we were under the
impression that we had all the paperwork
done for the dogs we were there with the
dogs in front of everybody
uh
there might have been other things
smuggled
but not dogs well they seem to miss that
bit
so since the dogs failed to go through
customs and adhere to australia's
required 10-day quarantine in july 2015
amber was officially charged with two
counts of illegally importing the
animals and how are the dogs are they
good yes they're good despite attempts
by certain
rogue
thug australian government officials
they are all right uh we're one because
it became like this snowball effect
i cannot believe that this we it's a sad
state of affairs um that that made
such headline global news i'll just say
that it is sad they're back on american
soil yes my little yorkies are with me
that following year johnny and amber
even issued an apology for not following
the australian rules australia is a
wonderful island with a treasure trove
of unique plants animals and people it
has to be protected when you disrespect
australian law they will tell you firmly
i am truly sorry that pistol and boo
were not declared
protecting australia is important
declare everything when you enter
australia
and after she pled guilty to falsifying
travel documents in court the case was
closed but now the spokesperson says
that the case is actually ongoing
[Music]